hey this is super weird and it's
spreading like wildfire and I don't
really get what's going on Melania Trump
has liked on Twitter our video
questioning how she got an Einstein visa
remember that last week we did a story
about Melania Trump coming to the United
States and the story was called on
YouTube how exactly did Melania Trump
get an Einstein visa and the story got
some attention as of this morning it had
about 25,000 views on YouTube and I got
a bunch of emails about it but then
overnight late last night a Twitter user
named David Elrod tweeted out the video
and the official Melania Trump Twitter
account the verified Melania account
with nearly a million followers liked
the tweet with our video and if you're
watching at this point in time you'll
see on your screen that Melania Trump's
account with its nine hundred and
seventy five thousand followers had
three likes as of last night around 1:00
a.m. Eastern Time one of those three
likes is this video from the David
Pakman show YouTube channel how exactly
did Melania Trump get an Einstein visa
now by this morning two of those three
likes were removed or unliked which you
can do on Twitter and so if you go to
Melania Trump's Twitter account now you
will see that there are no longer three
liked tweets but only one and our tweet
our video rather is no longer one of the
things that she likes what the hell is
going on here right I mean the there's
no doubt at all at this point that
Melania Trump is aware of our coverage
of her on the David Pakman show the only
way around that would be that she was
hacked sort of like the Ted Cruz excuse
but again if someone hacked Melania
Trump's Twitter account why is it that
they're gonna like a random clip from
the David Pakman show of all things so I
don't think for a second that there's a
hacking sort of situation here
whatsoever so then I started thinking
well is it an attempt at satire by
Melania Trump is it subtle trolling
which we've already speculated and
people on our Twitter on a reddit have
been saying is Melania trolling Trump
because she's liked a bunch of really
odd tweets including a tweet by Barack
Obama and all this different stuff has
her Twitter account bin
managed by someone in her office who
thought this was a good idea I don't
know but I think the most likely
scenario is that it's some kind of
avant-garde performance art no I'm
kidding I think the most likely scenario
is Melania Trump was trying to watch
this video and accidentally hit the like
button on her mobile device or something
like that and then when her staff caught
it
they unliked it that's my thought
probably because we weren't saying the
nicest things about no in that video not
it obviously layoffs but the fact that
she was able to get 9 signed visa raised
a lot of questions for us many many
questions and I I don't know what her
thought would be I mean listen I don't I
don't I don't think I have to say this
but she's welcome on the program any
time if this is a subject matter that
she's interested in talking to me about
although obviously that's never going to
happen but there's an article in the New
York Daily News about the fact that she
liked our video the article quotes me
we're linking to it in the YouTube clip
for this story an article in The Daily
Mail which is you said it's a
conservative sort of a right it is it
kind of like a not not a like scandal
tabloid type but doesn't it go in that
direction does entirely but it's
legitimate publication that's yes no
doubt about it it's not Infowars let's
put it that way
AOL which shockingly aol's there's still
a thing called AOL News America Online
they have an article about the fact that
Melania Trump liked our video and my
expectation is that by the time people
watch this clip there will be even more
articles about this yeah I'm pretty
starstruck over here honestly oh me too
if Melania Trump's watching I want to
make sure I look okay I sort of played
out this whole scenario in my head where
like she's sitting there on Air Force
two or something like that and she's on
her phone and she comes across our video
hits play but then instead she actually
hit like so then she actually plays it
and I'm like going through the entire
thing of Melania Trump actually watching
the clip clip which is super interesting
my mom's I think this I don't know that
we have any reason to think Michelle
Obama ever saw one of our clips so the
fact that Melania seems to be a
consuming content from the show it's
fantastic maybe we will ever maybe at
some point we will get an answer about
this and I hope that at some point
milania's representatives her
spokespeople the spokespeople for the
first lay
issue a comment about this that would be
fascinating and you better believe that
will cover it too we will no doubt cover
it discuss this with us on our subreddit
already people picked up on the fact
that this is going on and there's a
threat going on about it david
pakman.com slash our IDI di t we'll be
back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by Foote or which is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you can open the
game up on your phone or in your web
browser you'll see a range of forecasts
covering topics really across the board
I mean it's politics sports everything
in between really and you wager on
predictions about real world events but
using food tours in-game fake currency
and you earn more of that currency every
time you make a prediction that comes
true so you can show off your prediction
skills if you have any dear friends you
can improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on fat or you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube this week on future I posed
the question is Congress going to raise
the minimum gun buying age federally to
21 years old by the end of this year by
the end of 2018 what do you think click
the link in the description place your
bets you can also browse the politics
category make other wagers and you can
sign up now at foote or dot-com and
start making your own forecasts on
political topics and whatever else is
interesting to you totally free
available on both Android and iOS as
well as on web browsers at fut you you
are calm